5 km au total neuf villes de
l'agglomération concernait une partie de
la voirie de saint quentin en yvelines
se refait une beauté durant l'été cjso
travaux d'aménagement soit d'entretien
des voiries existantes
vous savez qui est un patrimoine
important sur cinquantaine d'amputés j
soit de rénover soit de requalifier des
voiries si on a un axe important
notamment de rendre la suppression plus
plus pacifié pour les circulations
douces donc on fait aussi des travaux
d'aménagement de pistes cyclables
complémentaires par exemple 12
opérations sont prévues
l'ensemble des travaux est
majoritairement financée par
l'agglomération
ils se dérouleront jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'août se brosse minimiser les
nuisances un qui dit raos devant reed
réflexion de vori veut dire blocage sans
fermeture des voiries ou moins
partiellement notamment sur lorsqu'on a
des travaux de nuit
déviation des réseaux de bus également
puis dit forcément un peu d'encombrement
tout l'intérêt c'est de faire ça là où
le minimum de nuisances possibles et les
gros travaux continuent aussi comme les
aménagements de la rn10 à trappes dans
un travail d'enfouissement voirie qui
donc là les travaux on va accélérer cet
été notamment sur la deuxième quinzaine
du mois d'août avec la démolition de
l'ancien pont quand on cachait un qui
surplombe la n10 et avec un premier nom
qui vient d'être installé
c'est sans doute dû travailler plus
important en terme d'impact à venir ici
avec un budget qui n'est pas que 50 ans
ces travaux de rénovation occasionne des
déviations de bus ou des fermetures de
routes
la commune n'a pas ralenti le calendrier
le nombre de chantiers n'a pas augmenté
pour cet été 2011 21